It's chef Ludo Lefebvre and Natasha Leggero.
Thanks Drew.
(audience cheers)
Thank you.
Thank you, okay, Natasha.
Yes?
Or, as Ludo, will you say Natasha's name?
Natasha.
Yes!
(Natasha laughs)
Now I know.
Natasha.
Yeah, every time you say it in the show
it makes me so happy.
I am loving the show.
It's different, you guys have a fresh take
on a cooking show.
I'm so into the premise.
Yeah, so basically it's six chefs.
Six, new chefs, every episode.
And it's sort of like a culinary who done it.
So, they're trying to impress Ludo with their dishes.
But what they don't realize
is that one of them is a rat
and they're there to sabotage all of the dishes.
So, if Ludo likes the food,
then the team gets the money.
But if he thinks it's disgusting,
then the rat will get the money.
And so you kind of follow along.
And we followed along too.
Isn't that fun?
A taste of venture.
I love it.
(audience claps)
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪